Weeds can be defined in a variety of ways:
a plant growing where it isn’t wanted, a
plant that interferes with farming or grazing,
a plant that was not intentionally sown, a
plant that is persistent and detrimental to
the plants around it, among others.
Basically, what it comes down to is that weeds
are plants that humans don’t want to have
around for one reason or another.
In the United States, there is a federal weed
list and many states have their own weed lists,
too.
Some common flowers appear on the state weed
lists yet appear in gardens and flower bouquets
across the country.
For instance, baby’s breath (Gypsophila
paniculata) is considered a noxious weed in
California, while the ox-eye daisy (Chrysanthemum
leucanthemum), your typical white daisy with
the golden centre, is considered a weed in
numerous states, including Colorado, Kansas,
Ohio, and West Virginia.
Some weeds are simply plants that are not
wanted in the place where they are growing,
but are useful at other times.
For instance, a wild raspberry plant smothering
a crop of strawberries planted by a farmer.
In other areas, a weed might be an invasive
species of plant which threatens a country’s
natural flora.
An example of this is broom, or Cytisus scoparius,
which grows abundantly in Scotland and is
used in ornamental landscaping, sand dune
stabilization, and wasteland reclamation.
It was even used as a symbol of the Plantagenet
kings.
However, in Australia, New Zealand, and parts
of North America, it is considered a pest
species and often eradicated.
Sometimes weeds were considered undesirable
in the Old World before they came to the new
one.
Weed seeds were unintentionally spread after
they were mixed in with seeds of other plants,
like those of vegetables.
Other times, farmers found weeds useful to
help other plants grow—such as sweet briar
in New Zealand, which was used to help grafted
roses grow, and then became a pest when it
spread.
Typically, weeds also possess certain characteristics
that make them particularly irritating to
the human race: they grow and spread very
quickly, which can hurt the surrounding plants
by depriving them of sunshine and nutrients
in the soil.
Their spread can be attributed to their abundant
seed production and the hardiness of those
seeds, which can lay dormant in the soil for
long periods of time.
Weeds themselves are also hardy, often able
to live in extreme conditions and in places
affected by human interference.
To sum it up, weeds are typically extremely
difficult to exterminate from a garden bed
entirely.
Other than acting as an invasive species in
new areas, weeds also are often considered
such as they are plants that pose a threat
to farmers and their crops.
Weeds can contaminate crops, reducing crop
quality; they can host diseases which kill
the crop; shelter insects in the winter which
will then eat the crop; and they could also
produce toxins, infecting the crop with chemicals
that are dangerous for human consumption.
Needless to say, farmers tend to want to keep
weeds away from their crops.
They spend billions of dollars every year
on herbicides to keep weeds at bay, but even
that doesn’t stop all of them.
Additional money is lost on crops that fail
or are contaminated because of weeds.
Their loss in profit means higher prices at
the grocery store for the consumer.
Despite all of the flaws of weeds, many do
have some benefits, too.
They provide soil stabilization and nectar
for bees.
They can be food for wildlife or even humans,
as well as occasionally used for medicinal
purposes.
And, of course, as alluded to, weeds are big
business and many jobs are created because
of them.
After all, how many fewer workers would be
needed and fewer home lawn and garden products
if weeds were as easy to kill as that houseplant
you’re always struggling to keep alive.